The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So welcome back.
Today, we're going to look
at the modular synthesizer.
And our area of focus
right now is still
looking at musical interfaces.
A lot of people present
the modular synthesizer
in the context of basic
synthesis techniques
and the development of
musical instruments.
I think it's very
useful for us to think
of the modular synthesizer as
a type of musical interface,
and particularly the
interface available
through the creative patching
and combination of modules.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to look at a little bit of
the history of the development
of modular synthesizers,
starting with the giant RCA
synth, and then
moving on to the Moog.
We're going to spend a little
time with the basic Moog design
and look at some of the
basic synthesis techniques.
We're going to do
that by looking
at the emulation of
virtual Moog that we
have available through
Arturia's very nice virtual Moog
instrument plug-in, which
is going to give us a way
to hear some of the sounds
and see some of the approaches
to patching this instrument.
And then next time we meet in
workshop mode next Tuesday,
we're going to build some
similar designs in PD
using the Martingale
Library and explore
some of these
approaches, as well.
We're going to listen to some
music and then if we get to it,
talk about some
semi-modular synths.
And see the design go from
fully modular synthesizers
to semi-modular and
non-modular synthesizers, which
is a valuable trajectory to see.
So coming up on the horizon, we
have a brief quiz on Thursday.
Keep that in mind.
Your music technology
case studies--
the draft is due on Tuesday.
If you have any questions about
this as you approach this,
feel free to drop me
an email or the like.
And that's it for now.
Any questions?
OK.
So now with the
modular synthesizer,
we see numerous things
start to come together.
We saw in the early studios
used by Varese, by Stockhausen,
and others, this cobbling
together of various components
and interconnecting them
into sound-producing devices.
We see with the
modular synthesizer
these components
start to solidify
into a single common
collection of entities.
With these semi-modular
designs, we
see this solidification
happen even more.
And the designs solidify
into a single common thing.
There wasn't anything shockingly
new about the technologies used
in the modular synthesizer.
Again, they were
technologies that
had been around
for 10 or 20 years.
But really, the
interface, and the design,
and the integration of these
components, in my view,
was the really important thing.
Voltage control-- the ability
to interconnect and control
these devices with
voltages-- was really
the key technology that made
this synthesizer more flexible,
more powerful, and more
creative for the operator.
Now we start with the RCA
synthesizer, which isn't really
a modular synthesizer.
To my knowledge, this device
had a fairly fixed signal path.
So it wasn't really modular.
It had components.
But you couldn't
interconnect the components
with patch cords.
You couldn't radically
change the type of sounds
that it made.
Now this synthesizer came
in two different forms.
There was the first one, which
later became known as the Mark
I and then the Mark II,
the later version of this.
This synthesizer was the result
of quite a bit of research
by Olson and Belar,
who were working
at RCA for a number of years.
The Holmes text nicely
describes their early research
with music synthesis
technologies.
Does anybody recall
what they were
trying to do in the
beginning-- Olson and Belar.
Their first attempt
at synthesis was
directed towards this
certain activity.
Anybody recall?
They were trying to synthesize
Steven Walter pop tunes-- pop
melodies-- basic melodies,
using essentially Markov chains.
And they were trying to
create a machine that
could compose simple melodies
by analyzing basic tunes
and then re-synthesizing them.
In that process, they
developed some technologies
for creating
oscillators and filters.
And that led to their
first RCA synthesizer.
So this device used essentially
tuning-fork-based oscillators.
So their basic oscillator
was a tuning fork
that was set in motion and
picked up electromagnetically.
And that signal was then divided
to shift into different octaves
and transformed into a square
wave to create a rich tone.
And then they filtered
that tone to create
the variety of timbres that
the instrument could make.
The device featured
a number of filters,
as well-- high- and low-pass
filters and this really kind
of bizarre resonator
chain, which
is an interesting
selective filter.
This image here is from
their first publication
on the synthesizer from 1955.
And it's also reproduced
in the Holmes book.
We can see the basic way
that the synthesizer worked.
Information was encoded on
something kind of like a piano
roll, but just storing
control information
in a binary representation.
Here, rather than
using a vacuum,
brushes are used to pick up
when an opening in the hole
was to trigger a circuit.
The frequency source
here is those oscillators
controlled by tuning forks.
And that signal is then
split by the octiver.
And then it has the
frequency glider,
which allows the transition
between pitches, the growth,
and decay, which is a fancy
name for an envelope generator.
Or not fancy, I guess--
historic-- various high-pass,
low-pass filters,
volume control,
low-frequency
modulator, probably
for adding vibrato or other
slow changes to the sound.
Resonator change--
that's that unique filter
I was talking about--
timbre control, probably
additional filters.
Or I'm not exactly sure what
that last component did.
But that's something to look at.
And then finally, all going
to a nice record cutter,
which allowed you
to record the sound.
So there were two
nearly identical voices
that could be used and
controlled by this paper roll.
So partly out of Olson and
Belar's earlier research
in synthesizing pop tunes,
they approached a synthesizer
as a device that needed to be
controlled, not by a keyboard,
not by some other
type of interface,
but by a type of notation.
And their notation was this
punched-hole paper record,
which again, is kind of like
a piano roll but different.
Because rather than a one-to-one
relationship with parameters
and their values,
these are essentially
three- and four-bit codes that
determine frequency, octave,
timbre, the envelope growth
and decay, and volume.
So frequency is determined by
these four on-and-off switches,
which give us 16
possible values.
But they only used 12.
Octave could be selected.
Similarly here, timbre, the
envelope, volume, et cetera.
This roll right there shows
us the necessary information
to encode these six pitches.
So you can imagine working
with this device would
be a little tedious.
But it offered explicit,
complete control.
This nice diagram, also
from that original article,
shows us a massive
simplification of the device,
going from reading the
roll, to the two synthesizer
channels, mixer, amplifier, and
then a direct-to-disk cutting
lathe.
Some notable thing
about this-- it
was really the first
attempt to parameterize
musical information in a very
rigorous and complete way.
We saw with the player
piano an earlier attempt
at parameterization.
But here, we're starting
to parameterize timbre,
amplitude envelopes, and
volume and level controls
at a greater degree than we
had with the player piano.
Also important about
this instrument
is it was not designed
for performance.
It was really designed
as a machine where
you composed in
advance and played back
what you had notated.
That was the Mark
I. The Mark II was
housed at Princeton University.
And that started a relationship
with Columbia and Princeton
University, which led to
Columbia and Princeton
getting a grant from the
Rockefeller Foundation
to buy the second version of
this synth-- the RCA Mark II.
This synth was very
similar to the Mark I,
except for it added a
white-noise generator, which
was useful for creating a
variety of noisier percussive
sounds.
It had four voices
instead of two.
It had a microphone input.
And it had some variable
frequency oscillators.
Similar to the RCA Mark I, it
was a room-sized giant beast
of a synthesizer.
In this picture, we can
see the disk cutters here.
We can see, also, some tape.
Eventually, they did
add tape machines.
And we can see the
paper readers there.
Notice that we don't see,
really, a patch bay or patch
cords.
This was a modular synthesizer
in that had modules.
But it wasn't freely
interconnectable in the way
that we later find with our
Moog and Buchla synthesizers.
Now I sent you guys the link
to this demo recording, which
has this great narrator
helping us along the way.
This demo record
was made in 1955.
I believe it was a
recording of the Mark II.
The reason why is because
in this demonstration,
they use a filtered white noise.
And I think this is a
very nice example where
they tried to synthesize the
sound of a complete dance band.
So they had four voices.
So they used some of the
voices for bass, percussion,
and melody.
Let's listen to
a little of this.
[HIGH-PITCHED SYNTHESIZER BEEPS]
PROFESSOR: That's
the high-hat sound.
[LOW-PITCHED SYNTHESIZER BEEPS]
PROFESSOR: And that's the bass.
[SYNTHESIZER]
PROFESSOR: And here's
everything altogether.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-We can also
synthesize a part where
each tone has a rapid growth
and slow decay, like this.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Let's go
back to that dance band.
[LOW-PITCHED SYNTHESIZER BEEPS]
PROFESSOR: Come on.
[SYNTHESIZED MUSIC]
PROFESSOR: There we go.
Notice the white noise being
used for the snare-like sound
there.
So as this demo record shows,
and as the history of Olson
and Belar's work
shows, they were
very interested in
using the synthesizer
to generate pop music,
which is interesting.
Because what it became used
for was not popular music,
but music of composers
like Milton Babbitt, Mario
Davidovsky, and other
composers working
at the Columbia-Princeton
studios.
One of our listenings for today
was "Philomel," Babbitt's 1964
composition that used
the RCA synthesizer.
Let's listen to a
little bit of this
to remind you guys
what this sounds like.
[MUSIC -- MILTON BABBITT,
"PHILOMEL"]
PROFESSOR: So
there's three sources
of sound in this composition.
What are they-- three
sources of sound?
AUDIENCE: There's the voice.
PROFESSOR: Right,
the live voice.
AUDIENCE: There's
the synthesizer.
Not sure what the third was.
PROFESSOR: Anybody
notice or recall?
There's also pre-recorded voice.
So there's some tape-recorded
and processed voice sounds
in here, which are used to
create some very nice distance
echo and some
depth to the voice.
And actually in my view, one
of the most interesting things
about this piece is
how the tape part
blends with the synthesis
and acts as an intermediary.
Thoughts about this piece?
AUDIENCE: It's very sporadic.
PROFESSOR: Sporadic-- what
do you mean, sporadic?
AUDIENCE: Very jagged.
I don't know.
It's not really-- they
follow a certain pattern.
But there's not a ton of tune.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, there's this
jagged, jerky, gestural shape
to a lot of the musical parts.
And that's clear in the voice
and also in the synthesizer
parts.
AUDIENCE: As the piece
goes on, the voice
smooths out a
little bit, though,
if I remember correctly.
And then the synthesizer's still
doing the jagged [INAUDIBLE].
So it has the background
interjections, I guess.
It seems like longer stretches.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, let's
jump to the end in here.
[MUSIC -- MILTON BABBITT,
"PHILOMEL"]
PROFESSOR: Now Babbitt was
using a method of organization
that we have talked
about previously.
What was that method
of organization?
AUDIENCE: Serialism.
PROFESSOR: Serialism, or
the 12-tone technique.
Did the RCA synthesizer
provide facilities
for 12-tone composers?
Was it well suited for that?
I mean, Olson and Belar wanted
to use it to do popular music.
AUDIENCE: You had absolute
control over everything, right?
So it was perfect.
PROFESSOR: Right.
All your parameters
were fixed on the roll.
So you could compose very
carefully crafted lines
in a very organized way.
And that's very much
what we hear here.
It's kind of, I think, ironic
in that Olson and Belar imagined
this instrument
originally to create
an endless variety
of pop tunes to sell
in the commercial market.
And of course, it
ended up being used
to create some very esoteric,
non-commercial music
in the end.
And that's one of
our many examples
of unintended consequences
of certain technologies.
Other comments or
reflections on this piece?
AUDIENCE: I thought
it was really
cool to use the
operatic voice with it,
as opposed to other
singing styles.
Because in conjunction
with the synthesizer,
the strange timbre
of operatic singing
became this thing that
was more like a thing
to listen to than typically
what operatic singing is about.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
that's interesting.
For me, the really striking
thing is the vibrato.
Because the vibrato
is really, really
wide-- contrast between that
wide vibrato and the more flat
tones we're getting
out of the synthesizer.
Are you hearing
something else, as well?
AUDIENCE: No, that's
the sort of thing.
But then also in the
tape-modulated parts.
Because he speeds her
up and slows her down.
And so this thing happens
with the vibrato right
where they like.
It was very tight, or
even looser and lower.
And there's this
really, I think,
great interplay between that
and the synthesized sounds.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I agree.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
the sound I heard
reminded me a lot
of science fiction.
PROFESSOR: Uh-huh. [LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: There seems
to be a common thread
about that recording.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Well, a lot of the early
sounds of early synthesizers
were used in science fiction and
film, since Forbidden Planet,
and even before that
with the theremin.
The connection has been
there for some time.
We don't hear a lot of
variety of timbres and colors
with the synthesizer.
A lot of it is sinusoidal
or filtered waveforms.
So there's not a huge variety
of sounds out of the synth.
But it didn't provide a
tremendous amount of control,
as we can tell by looking
at the control information
available on the tape.
AUDIENCE: Do you know
anything about how
it was serialed, whether he
used all of his parameters
in the serial way?
I was trying to parse it
out, and I had no idea.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I mean, it's worth
looking at further.
I suspect, given
Babbitt's inclinations,
that both pitch and the other
parameters were serialized.
So it's very likely
he had the opportunity
to serialize envelopes
and serialize
the timbre controls
of the synth.
So I think it's very
likely that he probably
did, which is similar to an
approach taken by Stockhausen,
who was rigorously exploring
some of these things.
But with the RCA synthesizer,
this became very notatable
in a way that wasn't
possible before.
Do you have another comment?
OK.
So two innovators followed
the RCA synthesizer
with devices that were
more flexible than the RCA
synthesizer.
They were more flexible in
that they allowed the operator
to reconnect the
modules in various ways.
Rather than that fixed sequence
of oscillator, filter, et
cetera, these devices
allowed the operator
to interconnect them in a
variety of different ways
and also allowed the
operator to control them
in a variety of different
ways, not with punched paper
but with various types
of input devices.
Buchla generally gets credit
for coming a little bit
before Moog.
His devices were very diverse
and often custom-designed
for particular people,
particular studios.
His interest as a
composer himself
was in creating diverse
and unique instruments,
not really in creating
a commercial market
for the synthesizer.
So he not only explored a wide
variety of different modules
that use noise and
randomness in different ways,
but also various
types of input devices
other than the keyboard.
And our readings for today
emphasize the point about how
Buchla initially didn't want
a keyboard control for his
instrument, and
Moog embraced that,
which is an issue we'll talk
about when we talk about
the [? Pinchen-Trocho ?]
reading.
In 1965, he releases
the Buchla Box
without a keyboard-- a
very popular instrument.
1970, he has this 200
series Electric Music Box,
which you can see there.
Also doesn't have a
keyboard, but has a variety
of sliders, knobs, and
other interface components.
In the '70s, he released
some portable devices.
This one, although apparently I
think Holmes says that only 200
of these were made-- wouldn't
you like one of these?
He did use a keyboard at times.
But notice that this is a
touch-sensitive keyboard
and probably does some
things we wouldn't expect.
A small, portable
modular synthesizer--
if you can find one
of these, get it.
[LAUGHS]
Buchla is still
making synthesizers.
They're very expensive.
But they really offer
some unique designs.
Looking at his designs--
you can go to his website--
are really fascinating, creative
approaches to the synthesizer.
Buchla is a separate
thread from that of Moog.
Because Moog's instruments
were dedicated to meeting the
needs-- the demands--
of musicians.
Our readings make
that very clear.
He worked with musicians
in a variety of ways.
He invited musicians
to come to his factory
and explore his instruments.
He adapted his instruments
to the demands of musicians
in order to meet their needs,
and really, through that,
made a very successful
commercial instrument.
Now we've already
talked about how
Moog got started with
the theremin as a kid,
creating theremin
kits in his garage.
In 1954, he published this
article in Radio and Television
News about his design for
a tube-based theremin.
This article's great.
You can check it out online.
It also has the whole schematic
diagram for the circuit.
At this time in
the '40s and '50s,
there was this whole
kit-bit building culture,
and a lot of interest
in building theremin.
So his design
became very popular
and attracted a
lot of attention.
He published another
article in 1961
using a transistor-based
theremin that was actually
featured on the cover
of this magazine
and also got him a
lot of attention.
He, by then, had a business.
He and his dad were selling
theremins out of their garage--
theremin kits.
By the '60s, he meets a
composer by the name of Deutsch,
who knew Moog because
of the theremin--
his theremin kits-- and
wanted to know about, well,
if he can do some other types
of synthesizing devices--
some other types of
devices that allowed
you to take basic oscillators,
interconnect them, and put them
under flexible control.
Moog develops his first
synthesizer, the 900 Series,
in 1965.
This device wasn't
distributed broadly.
It was used mostly by
composers and some studios.
In 1966, he patents
his low-pass filter,
which becomes a very important
part of his synthesizer.
Because it allowed to take
a rich, wide bandwidth
sound and control its timbre
and give it a very crisp tone.
We'll hear some of that
sound very shortly.
People say that this was the
only thing that Moog patented.
But there are some other patents
associated with the Moog name.
It was definitely the first
device that he patented.
And the low-pass filter
was novel in that it
had a particularly
steep roll-off curve.
So it was able to really focus
the sound underneath the cutoff
frequency.
And it had an
adjustable resonance,
which provided a nice peak
at that cutoff frequency.
Now it's in 1967
that he releases
his first real commercial
product, the series Systems 1,
2, and 3.
This is an earlier device.
We can see with this
one, the keyboard.
We can see some of
the basic modules.
And we can see, also, a ribbon
controller, another type
of input device
that he explored.
This got later
refined into devices
of this sort, which
is very often what
we see when we imagine
the Moog synthesizer.
Here we have a number of
oscillators, filters, up here.
And this over here
is a sequencer,
which we're actually going
to talk about sequencing
next time we meet-- also,
the keyboard and the ribbon
controller, as well.
So with the Systems
1, 2, and 3 in 1967,
there was some standard
packages you could buy.
But you could still
buy individual modules
for your own synthesizer.
And this nice
price list shows us
some of the prices
of these devices.
We could get a
voltage-controlled amplifier
for $150-- fair price.
That voltage-controlled
low-pass, high-pass filter,
$475 for one filter in 1968.
That's pretty expensive.
These synthesizers were
extremely expensive.
But they started to be
sold and commercialized.
And people started to buy them.
But one thing in particular led
to the explosion of the Moog
industry, and that was Wendy
Carlos's Switched-on Bach
recording, recorded in
1968, released in '69,
and garnered a huge
amount of attention
to the Moog synthesizer.
We'll talk about Wendy
Carlos and her recording
in a little bit.
But let's review
some of the concepts
of the modular synthesizer.
So we have two basic components.
We have things that
generate sound,
like our oscillators
and other devices.
And we have components
that modify those sounds.
So we have these
two different types
of modules that can be
interconnected and modified.
The input four module
is either the knobs
on the front panel
or another voltage.
And some devices
allow you to switch
between using the knob
or a voltage as an input,
or using both-- using the
knob to set a basic level
and then the input voltage
to adjust it further.
The output of these
modules is another voltage,
which can be interconnected to
modules further down the line.
Within the modular synthesizer,
we have two types of signals.
We have control signals
and audio signals.
Both of these,
depending on the design,
can be interconnected
in various ways.
Audio signals are
the things that we're
used to-- sounds represented
as a bipolar voltage.
Voltage ranges would generally
between negative 3 and 3 volts.
Sometimes higher or wider
ranges were possible.
Control signals were also
voltages but generally unipolar
voltages between maybe
0 and plus 5 volts.
These were often
more slowly moving
signals that could
be used to control
the parameters of
another module.
Control signals were used,
obviously, to shape envelopes.
And these envelopes
could be applied
to parameters other than
the amplitude of the sound,
such as a cutoff
frequency or the like.
Now a key concept of
the modular synthesizer
was the ability to
reuse the modules.
We could use an oscillator
to produce a tone
and hear that tone
of the oscillator.
We could also use an
oscillator to shape
the amplitude of a sound
and produce a tremolo,
or to modulate the frequency
of another oscillator
and produce a vibrato, or use
the output of an oscillator
to modulate the cutoff
frequency to create
a variable timbre to a sound.
I'm going to demonstrate
all of those in a second.
This ability to reuse these
modules-- to mix audio signals
and control signals and
transform one to the other--
was really the key feature
of the modular synthesizer,
combined with voltage
control, and gave it
a great degree of flexibility.
Now in this golden age of
the modular synthesizer,
when you sat down
to this instrument,
you got nothing for free.
You sat down.
It didn't make any sound.
In order to make a sound, you
had to design an instrument.
So the interface, in order to
make a sound, became patching.
You had to patch
to make a sound.
No sounds were given to you.
And this promoted a huge degree
of freedom and creativity
in the design of sounds.
We see, over the
history of synthesizers,
this start to decrease.
And so in the late '60s is
when we have the most freedom.
And as the '70s move
on, we see synthesizers
that reduce the
ability of patching
and make it easier to get
a sound more automatically.
And then by the early
'80s, we have synthesizers
that are programmable but
have very little in terms
of a customizable interface.
Some of the basic components
of the synthesizer-- these
are screenshots
of virtual synths,
which is kind of amusing.
But they allow us
to see more clearly
some of the designs
of these synthesizers.
So our basic oscillators, or
voltage-control oscillators,
generally provided a
control for frequency.
Often, the range of
the frequency knob
would be variable in steps.
So we have a dedicated
low-frequency switch
for low-frequency oscillators.
And then we have
various higher ranges,
which use the terminology
derived from organs--
32 foot, 16 foot, 8
foot, and the like.
We had the ability to
get different waveforms
from the same
oscillator, which is
a nice convenience
of such devices.
We have various noise sources,
and we'll hear example of those
as well.
And we have a sample on
hold generators, which
allow us to take an input signal
and sample it periodically
to create a stepped shape.
I'll demonstrate that in
a little bit, as well.
Now our modular
synthesizers usually
had some sort of mixing
control-- some ability
to combine signals.
And this sometimes was under
control of another voltage.
So we have voltage-control
amplifiers, or VCAs.
Sometimes we have
mixers that use
various toggles or
on-off switches.
This is from the design
of the Minimoog, where
the various oscillators had
a level control and then
a toggle switch.
And some devices
had various types
of matrix-mixing and
patching controls,
which are very, very cool.
This EMS synthesizer--
the Synthi,
Synth-I-- allowed you to control
the routing of signals, rather
than through patch
cords through a matrix.
This was a template
used to help you
remember your patch
with this synth.
These synths are very cool.
If you can find one, grab it.
Notice the convenient handle.
You can take it with you.
All of our synthesizers have
various types of filters.
A VCF, or
voltage-control filter,
allows you to adjust
the parameters
with a voltage, the low-pass
filter and high-pass filter
being the most common,
a band-pass filter
and other varieties also found.
In our modular synthesizer,
we have various types
of envelope generators.
The envelope is
a unipolar signal
that we can apply to the
amplitude of a sound.
But we can also
apply the envelope
to other musical parameters.
The key thing about an
envelope is its control signal
that's designed to be triggered.
It's a control signal
that's designed
to start at a certain
time and end, as opposed
to something like a
low-frequency oscillator that
is continuous and ongoing.
The ADSR is probably
the most common type
of envelope control on these
early modular synthesizers,
although there were
other varieties, as well.
There was AR filters and
attack-decay-sustain filters--
various simplifications
of the ADSR model.
The key approach to using
the modular synthesizer
at this time is often called
subtractive synthesis.
The idea of
subtractive synthesis
is we start with a
rich, complex tone,
and we use our filters to
take away from that tone
and get the sound
that we're looking at.
This is part of the reason
why Moog's low-pass filter was
so important.
Because we could start with
a complex tone and then
use the low-pass filter to
shape out the frequencies
that we did not want.
So our basic approach of
working in subtractive synthesis
would be to start with
a rich complex tone,
to cut out some of
those frequencies,
apply amplitude
envelopes to vary
the amplitude shape
of that sound,
and then use modulation
to vary the parameters.
And this starts to
become really interesting
when we modulate the modulators.
And we'll listen to what
that sounds like in a second.
Questions, comments, ideas?
OK.
So let's hear what
this sounds like.
Now probably the most
basic approach on one
of the most common approaches
to creating a complex sound
would be combining
multiple oscillators.
And this design is embodied
in some of the early Moog
synthesizers, where we
have three oscillators--
like these three oscillators
right here-- all under one
driver to control the
three oscillators.
The idea embodied
in the interface
here is that we're
going to create
a rich tone by
combining oscillators.
We can tune each of
these oscillators
to different octaves and
slight tuning differences.
But they're all going to
be under a single control.
Let's listen to what
this sounds like.
So our first example-- if we
start off with just a single
oscillator--
[LOW-PITCH SYNTHESIZER TONES]
So here, we're hearing
a sawtooth waveform.
And I'm taking it
from this oscillator
here and just dropping it
over into my big ADSR envelope
there.
If we want to hear a sign
tone, we can just replace that.
[SYNTHESIZER]
That's it.
A strong sign tone.
And we have our
triangle waveform here.
[SYNTHESIZER BEATS]
Our triangle waveform
sounds dead at that range.
[SYNTHESIZER BEATS AND TONE]
That's unexpected.
Let's go back to this.
I wonder if I--
[SYNTHESIZER]
There's our saw.
And then we have our
square wave, which also--
[FAINT SYNTHESIZER TONES]
--is not performing
well, strangely.
OK.
So that's our basic oscillators.
Now we can combine these
to create a rich tone.
So here, what I've
done is combine
the sound of three oscillators.
And let me tune them
all the same first.
[SYNTHESIZER]
So we're actually hearing
three oscillators.
And if you think about what you
think of a Moog sounding like,
this thick sound is very
much what we think about.
We're hearing sawtooth
and square waves here
at different octaves.
Let me vary the octaves
of this a little bit.
[SYNTHESIZER]
Hear that square wave at
the higher octave there?
[SYNTHESIZER]
Or if I move up one of
the sawtooth waves--
[SYNTHESIZER]
Or if I set them all
to low registers.
[LOW-PITCHED SYNTHESIZER TONES]
Now we can tune each of
these oscillators separately.
And a very common
practice would be
to make the oscillators
slightly out of tune
to create an even thicker sound.
So if I tune each
of these oscillators
out a little bit
from the center--
[SYNTHESIZER]
Let me go even further.
[DISCORDANT SYNTHESIZER TONES]
Now right there, it sounds
like out-of-tune oscillators.
But if I bring this
closer together--
[WAVERING SYNTHESIZER TONES]
--we get a thick sound, rather
than an out-of-tune sound.
Let me shift this one
up an octave or two.
[SYNTHESIZER]
And let me set this to be a
little bit more out of tune.
[WAVERING SYNTHESIZER TONES]
You don't hear it as
out-of-tune oscillators.
You hear it as a
single complex tone.
Now we can see already that most
of these early modular designs
were designed to be monophonic,
so produce one sound at a time.
Early on, it was
figured out that it'd
be pretty nice to
be able to control
the transition between
these monophonic voices.
And so we have the use
of a portamento control.
This was available in the
RCA synthesizer, as well.
And this would
often set the amount
of glide between
adjacent pitches.
So--
[SYNTHESIZER]
Right here, we're hearing
one note at a time.
If I set the glide--
[GLIDING SYNTHESIZER TONES]
That's a little long there.
Let me make it a little shorter.
[CHOPPY SYNTHESIZER TONES]
A little longer--
[GLIDING SYNTHESIZER TONES]
--which was used very
prominently by musicians--
[SYNTHESIZER]
--to create transitions
between notes,
and is really one of
the most common sounds
from these early
monophonic synthesizers.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the glide of it?
Because it seems like
a weird parameter
to become such a
central thing, or even
to decide that you need it right
there next to the keyboard.
It's the thing that you need.
So was there a reason?
Obviously there was
a reason for that.
But was it prominent in music
in a way that [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, I mean, if
a normal musician can control
this-- for instance, on a guitar
or other string instrument,
even a lot of wind
instruments, as well.
And I think the idea was
some musical passages
you would want to be staccato,
and short, and broken.
And other cases,
depending on the context,
you would want to have
that glide control.
If you want to make it
sound like a theremin,
you can set it all
the way up, and then
get continuous pitch variations.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: OK.
So our first step in
subtractive synthesis
is creating a complex tone.
And we've done that by combining
and de-tuning oscillators.
We can use a variety of
different wave shapes
with those oscillators.
And we can de-tune them.
And we can add three or-- I
don't know, should we go crazy?
[SYNTHESIZER]
If we want to add some
more, let's-- I don't know.
What does six sound like?
Let's see.
Let's throw in a sign tone.
[SYNTHESIZER]
That's kind of nice.
And let's throw in
another sawtooth.
[SYNTHESIZER]
[LAUGHS] OK.
You get the idea.
So we've produced
our complex tone.
The next basic step of
subtractive synthesis
is to apply a filter.
And this is where Moog's
patented low-pass filter comes
into play and why his steep
roll-off curve was so valuable.
We take our complex
tone generated
by three or more oscillators.
And we filter it.
And let's start off
with just the filtered--
[SYNTHESIZER]
OK.
We're a little bit ahead
of where we want to be.
Let's start first
with our complex tone.
[SYNTHESIZER]
There's our complex tone.
And our filter provides
cutoff frequency
to shape the timbre of that
sound and a resonance control
to set the amount of amplitude
on the peak of the cutoff
frequency.
[HIGH-PITCHED SYNTHESIZER TONES]
One of the design features
of Moog's low-pass filter
was that it could self-resonate.
So if the resonance
was set loud enough--
[SYNTHESIZER]
--we could actually produce
a very clear sinusoidal sound
at the cutoff frequency.
[SYNTHESIZER]
Yeah, you get the idea.
So there's our low-pass
filter-- taking our thick tone,
put it through a
low-pass filter.
One of the most common
things we want to do
and one of the easy advantages
of using a modular synthesizer
is we can take a sign tone,
or some other wave shape,
and use it to modulate
the cutoff frequency.
[STATICKY SYNTHESIZER TONES]
There it's a little fast.
Let me slow it down.
[PULSING SYNTHESIZER TONES]
So now we're modulating
the cutoff frequency
by a sign tone, whose
frequency I can control--
[SLOW WARPED SYNTHESIZER TONES]
--and whose depth
I can control here.
We would have to scale it.
This is much harder to
do with a real synth.
But this makes it nice and easy.
[SYNTHESIZER]
So a very common sound,
using a low-frequency
oscillator to control
the cutoff frequency.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there a
noticeable difference
if we modulate the cutoff
of the square or a sawtooth?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, let's hear it.
[SYNTHESIZER]
So yeah, you can
definitely notice it.
Because here, we're hearing
the smooth transition.
So let's try a square wave.
[SYNTHESIZER]
Right, so we hear
the step pattern.
If we speed this up, this
is actually pretty cool.
[SYNTHESIZER TONES WITH BEEPS]
We get a nice switching.
And then if we do the-- let's
try a triangle waveform.
It's not as smooth as a sign.
We'll get a--
[SYNTHESIZER]
[WARPED SYNTHESIZER TONES]
There we go.
So we get a different sound.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Oh, I just
wanted to clarify
that all the audio outputs are
also used as control outputs,
right?
There's no separation between--
PROFESSOR: Different synths
had different designs
in terms of that.
AUDIENCE: With the Moog, though.
PROFESSOR: With
the Moog, well, I
believe except for the
voltage ranges, sometimes
you would need to
scale an audio input.
Some devices, you would need
to transform your voltage
before you could use it.
But you could take
an audio oscillator
and use it as a control
voltage if it could perform
at a slow enough rate as a
low-frequency oscillator.
Some designs, you would need
a dedicated low-frequency
oscillator.
Because it couldn't perform
slowly in a reliable way.
That would be an issue
why sometimes there
would be a dedicated
low-frequency oscillator.
But with computers, doing
low-frequency oscillation
is easy.
So it's more interoperable.
AUDIENCE: Is there
some responsiveness
issue with that, where it seems
like you [? couldn't ?] do
really cool things if you
took audio signal that
was not synthesized but
recorded, and amplified,
and made to control things,
like a [INAUDIBLE], kind of.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Is there a
responsiveness issue?
Because what you were saying
before about control-voltage
versus audio signals is
that the control tends
to be at a slow--
like obviously,
audio is at a higher rate,
not [INAUDIBLE] not digital.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: With
that kind of thing,
is that a problem if you want
to modulate, say, the filter
with your voice?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Yeah, I mentioned in passing
that the RCA synthesizer had
a microphone input.
And Moog's synthesizers
had-- this one
doesn't show us a
good example of that--
but had microphone inputs.
We could take an analog
signal, use a low-pass filter
to smooth out the edges,
and use that to drive
some other parameters.
So it was possible
to take other inputs,
use them to control
your musical parameters.
That general
technique is something
we call envelope following.
And sometimes there would be
dedicated envelope followers
in these early synths to
make that even easier.
AUDIENCE: So like optimize
it for that, kind of?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK.
So what we just did was
have our dense combination
of oscillators.
And we use an LFO to shape
the sound in a periodic way.
A very common--
probably the most common
approach to
subtractive synthesis--
so common that it was embodied
in the design of the Minimoog
a few years later from the
time of this synthesizer--
was using an envelope to
control the cutoff frequency.
Why would you use an envelope
to control the cutoff frequency?
So with the LFO, we get
that continuous change
in the timbre, no matter
when we trigger the note.
Why would we want to use an
envelope, which we generally
use to control the
amplitude, to control
the cutoff frequency
of a filter?
Any ideas?
AUDIENCE: More like a
real instrument then,
if it's linked to when you
play, as opposed to continuous.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Many real instruments
have different timbres
over the course
of their envelope.
Many instruments are often
brighter at the initial onset--
the articulation-- and then
darken as the tone sustains.
So a very common approach is to
use a-- pull it up-- envelope.
And here, I'm using
an ADSR set to trigger
when I press a note
to control the cutoff
frequency of the filter.
And I'll start off with the
modulation of this being small.
[SYNTHESIZER]
Here on the onset-- the initial
little bump in the frequency--
let me make this broader.
[SYNTHESIZER]
And even broader.
And I'll start off with
the lower start point.
[SYNTHESIZER TONE BURSTS]
So that's an extreme setting.
We're using the ADSR to
control the cutoff frequency.
[SYNTHESIZER]
And I can adjust the attack.
So if the attack is quick,
we'll get a bright sound
at the very beginning
and then it'll get dark.
[SYNTHESIZER]
Ever hear a synthesizer sound
like that before, maybe?
Probably the most
common approach--
subtractive synthesis.
Use an envelope to
control the cutoff
frequency of a rich tone.
If I set the attack
to be longer--
[SYNTHESIZER]
--even longer still--
[LONG SYNTHESIZER TONE]
--we get a very slow increase
in the cutoff frequency.
And then that was so long, it
didn't even come back down.
There we go.
[SYNTHESIZER]
Good.
Questions?
So again, that
approach was so common,
it was embodied in nearly
almost every synthesizer that
came after the Moog,
this idea of applying
a filter to the
cutoff frequencies.
Some designs, like the Minimoog,
even had a dedicated envelope
just to control the
cutoff frequency.
So what else could we do
with the modular synthesizer?
Well, we could do amplitude
modulation and ring modulation,
where we modulate the
amplitude of the sound,
either with a sinusoidal
shape or some other shape.
And we can use this to
create tremolo effects when
we use a low-frequency
oscillator
or amplitude-modulation
or ring-modulation effects
as we speed up the modulation.
So in the first
example here, we're
taking the output of our
three oscillators here,
and we're putting them
into what is essentially
a voltage-controlled amplifier.
And we're modulating the
voltage of the amplifier
by another oscillator.
So--
[SHORT SYNTHESIZER TONE]
That was intentional.
[SYNTHESIZER TONES]
So this is an
oscillator controlling
the amplitude of our rich tone.
As we speed this up--
[SYNTHESIZER PULSE TONES]
--we get a sort
of tremolo sound.
And as we take this oscillator
into the audio range--
this is a great example
of being able to use
our modules for both audio and
control-rate signals-- we start
to get some amplitude-modulated
[SYNTHESIZER]
--sounds.
And if I increase
the modulation--
[DISTORTED SYNTHESIZER TONES]
--and again, low frequency.
[RAPID PULSING SYNTHESIZER
TONES]
And as before, we can
change the wave shape
of the amplitude modulation
between our other wave shapes.
So here, I'm using a sinusoid.
We could use squares,
or triangles,
or other shapes, as well.
Now of course, the next thing to
do is modulate the modulators.
So if I vary the modulation
of the modulator--
[LAUGHS] so here, I'm using
one oscillator to control
the frequency of another
oscillator that's being used
to control the amplitude
of our rich tone,
controlled by
three oscillators--
[PULSING SYNTHESIZER TONES]
--we get a gradual
shift from tremolo
to amplitude modulation
as I speed this up.
[SYNTHESIZER]
Let's see.
And let's try
something even faster
and see what that sounds like.
[PULSING SYNTHESIZER TONES]
Yeah, we're not hearing
the transition there.
[SYNTHESIZER]
And let's try one
more thing and see.
[SYNTHESIZER]
So there, we're doing
variable-rate amplitude
modulation, where the
variance and the rate--
[SYNTHESIZER]
--is determined by
this other oscillator.
Let's try one more at
this super high speed.
[RAPID SYNTHESIZER PULSE TONES]
All right.
You get the idea.
Questions?
So that's amplitude modulation.
Ring modulation--
closely related
to amplitude modulation.
Sometimes there would
be dedicated devices
for doing ring modulation.
On the Moog, there was a
dedicated ring modulator
that used a special circuit
that was quite popular later.
Let's just hear a
little bit about how
that ring motivation
sounds like.
[WARPED SYNTHESIZER TONES]
Now here, I'm using an
envelope to modulate
the frequency of ring
modulation so that we
get a dynamic contour over
the length of the event--
[WARPED SYNTHESIZER TONES]
--which is kind of fun.
Good.
So that's amplitude modulation.
We can use our oscillators
to control frequency
and the-- oh yeah, sure.
AUDIENCE: When you use an
envelope to control the cutoff
frequency of your
low-pass filter,
is that still the same
envelope of the output?
PROFESSOR: I'm using a
different envelope generator.
So it's like I'm using a
I'm triggering them
at the same time.
But I'm using a different
ADSR to control that cutoff
frequency.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: So I'm using
one ADSR to control
the output envelope
and another ADSR
to control the cutoff frequency.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do key
presses on the keyboard
trigger all of the whole thing?
PROFESSOR: It depends on the
design of the synthesizer
and what's going on.
For this emulation,
there's an easy way for us
to set the trigger
for envelopes.
And you see this
little red light right
there allows me to
set-- that envelope
is triggered when
a key press is set.
There's other ways to
trigger envelopes, as well.
So vibrato-- our very
basic approach to vibrato
is done by simply using
one of our oscillators.
This, of course, is why we
need so many oscillators.
Because we can use them
for so many things.
We're using one
of our oscillators
to modulate the frequency
of our complex tone.
[WARPED SYNTHESIZER TONES]
OK.
Well maybe that doesn't sound
much like a normal vibrato.
[WARPED SYNTHESIZER TONES]
So if we reduce the
degree of modulation--
[SLOWING WARPED SYNTHESIZER
TONES]
Let's make it a little slower.
[SLOWING SYNTHESIZER TONES]
OK.
Well, why don't we just
make it really wide?
[SYNTHESIZER TONES]
So we can go from something
like a normal vibrato
to very wide frequency sweeps.
We still don't
have something that
sounds like a more
human vibrato.
Does anybody know why
we don't have something
that sounds like
a human vibrato?
Anybody want to speculate?
It's constant, right?
The vibrato is constant
the whole time.
And often, musicians maybe
start off with a straight tone,
and then lean into the vibrato,
and then stop the vibrato.
AUDIENCE: And in that
case, you could just
modulate that modulator to
create that human [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So we can--
AUDIENCE: Envelope on the--
AUDIENCE: Right.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
We use an envelope to
scale the amplitude
of the low-frequency
oscillator that's
driving the
frequency modulation.
Again, what we do is we
take an ADSR envelope that's
being triggered when
the note starts.
And we're putting
that into one of
our voltage-controlled
amplifiers.
We're taking the output
of one of our oscillators,
and scaling the
output by that ADSR,
and taking the output of
that now modified control
signal to modulate the frequency
of our rich tone produced
by three oscillators,
which gives us--
[SYNTHESIZER]
--a vibrato that nicely
fades in and then fades out.
What determines
the fade-in time?
Well, it's the attack
of this envelope.
So if we want it to
come in right away--
[SYNTHESIZER]
--if we want it to
take a long time--
[SYNTHESIZER]
--the depth is set by our
voltage-control amplifier.
[SYNTHESIZER KNOCKING TONES]
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: OK, maybe I went
a little too far there.
[WARPED SYNTHESIZER TONES]
[LAUGHS] OK.
[LONG SYNTHESIZER TONES AND
TRILLS]
You get the idea.
So that's a great example
of using our modules
for a lot of different things.
We're using an oscillator to
create variation in frequency.
We're using one of our envelopes
to scale that variation
before applying it
to other oscillators.
Now as we started
to hear there, we
can push this frequency
modulation even further
and start to create
new harmonics.
Frequency modulation,
or FM modulation,
is when we modulate the
frequency at, or near,
or beyond the audio
rate, producing
even more frequencies and
then even more complex timbre.
Frequency modulation is often
done with assigned tones.
But we already have a rich tone.
So what if we just modulate
the frequency of our rich tone
at the audio rate?
I'll start with a slow--
[SYNTHESIZER]
You can hear it's already--
here's low frequency.
Let me speed it up.
[SYNTHESIZER]
And as I increase the
amount of modulation--
[VARYING SYNTHESIZER TONES]
--we get all sorts of
new spectral components
due to the frequency modulation.
And of course, we could scale
that frequency modulation.
We could modulate the modulator.
So we could control the
parameters of the modulation
with another oscillator
or another envelope.
And the process goes on and on.
Now a very common technique
available as early as the RCA
synthesizer-- we heard
a little taste of this--
was the use of filtered noise.
We can use our noise sources
through either a low-pass or
band-pass filter to
create some novel timbres.
This was used in that
example we listened
to before to create
a drum sound.
And it can be used for a
lot of interesting sounds.
Oh, sorry.
[SYNTHESIZER]
That was modulating
the modulator of FM.
Here's our
filtered-noise example.
[STATICKY SYNTHESIZER TONES]
So here I'm using a white-noise
source into a band-pass filter.
And I'm controlling
the cutoff frequency
of that band-pass
filter by the keyboard.
[STATICKY SYNTHESIZER TONES]
So we can create
something somewhat
in between a pitched
and unpitched sound.
[STATICKY AND WARPED SYNTHESIZER
TONES]
If we try with a
low-pass filter--
[SYNTHESIZER TAPS]
Let's see what this sounds like.
[VARYING SYNTHESIZER TAPS AND
BEEPS]
So that's simply noise through
a low-pass filter where
the cutoff frequency is
controlled by the keyboard,
which gives us the
ability to create--
[SYNTHESIZER BEEPS]
--some novel sounds.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What happens
when you modulate
the modulator with
the audio output?
[INAUDIBLE]
Can you even do
that on the Moog?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
On the Moog?
I'm not sure I
can do it on this.
But with a computer, we need
to insert a little bit of delay
in there.
We'll do that with PD.
When we work this with
PD, we'll feed that back
and see what happens.
You could use
feedback on the Moog,
particularly with delay,
which is something
that sometimes people would use.
Because we still had
the old tape technique.
So some people would
integrate tape delay
with the synthesizer,
send a signal out,
put it through tape
delay, bring it back in,
which allowed you to do some
pretty interesting things.
I believe we heard that in the
Oliveros tune, "Alien Bog."
She used a lot of tape delay.
The last example I
have for you guys
is one of the most common sounds
from the modular synthesizer,
or one of the many
common sounds.
And this is using
the sample and hold
generator applied to noise.
So here, what I'm doing
is taking white noise,
bringing it into the
sample-and-hold generator.
The sample and hold takes
that noise and samples
values from it in
a periodic fashion.
Here, I'm using the internal
trigger to sample the noise.
And I'm applying the output
of that to an oscillator
to do frequency modulation
of the oscillator.
So in short--
[SYNTHESIZER BEEPS]
--we get this.
Sound familiar?
[SYNTHESIZER BEEPS]
So what we're
doing, again, we're
taking noise and using it
as a source of randomness.
But the noise is coming
out at the audio rate.
So basically, what we need
to do is slow it down.
And the sample and hold gives
us a way to slow down a signal
and make it into
a stepped pattern.
[SYNTHESIZER]
Here, it's really slow.
I can speed it up.
[FASTER SYNTHESIZER TONES]
And even faster.
[RAPID SYNTHESIZER TONES]
And this sample and hold has
a nice glide parameter here,
which will smooth out the
transition between each step.
[SYNTHESIZER]
We spend all our time
gliding, and we don't even
get to the points.
[SYNTHESIZER]
Sample and holds
are a lot of fun.
Taking noise, putting
it through a sample
and hold-- a very powerful
way to get random parameters.
Here, we're hearing
those random parameters
scaled in a very
wide frequency range.
We can use it in a much
more narrow range--
[SYNTHESIZER]
--to create more subtle effects.
Let's see if we can
hear a random vibrato.
[SYNTHESIZER]
Oh, I need to scale
this even more.
[SYNTHESIZER]
Sort of a random vibrato--
a very unhuman approach
and one very idiomatic
to the synthesizer.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: The [INAUDIBLE]
is very digital, right?
PROFESSOR: Well, in a way.
I mean, the way that
analog-to-digital conversion
works is essentially through a
process of sampling and holding
the value.
But sample and hold processors
were available for a long time.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But it seems like
an in-between step,
between this idea of sampling
these individual values out
and then putting them out.
It's very digital, kind of.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, absolutely.
But then with this
glide control,
we get right back into
the smooth analog domain.
So that's--
AUDIENCE: It's just like a
A-B-C, B-A-C built together.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's true.
So--
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you showed us the
matrix, like the plug-in one.
Do they have virtual
versions of the matrix?
Or is it just a bad interface?
PROFESSOR: Oh, I think
it's a great interface.
But I don't know of
a virtualized version
of those EMS synths yet.
EMS really explore that.
And there is another
synthesizer-- look
at this, ARP 2500--
that use matrices
for the entire patching system.
I would love to see a
virtualization of that.
But I don't know of one yet.
AUDIENCE: It's sort
of like [INAUDIBLE]
matrix-based
controls [INAUDIBLE].
Does it do--
PROFESSOR: Max has a
matrix GUI control.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you can [INAUDIBLE]
things and [INAUDIBLE] similar,
but not--
PROFESSOR: Of course,
with this design,
depending on how
it's implemented,
you can do one-to-one
connections,
like with a patch bay.
But you can also do one-to-many
connections, as long
as that doesn't weaken
your signal too much.
Right.
So we listened to a
number of different pieces
using the modular
synthesizer-- various sorts.
Probably some of the
most important in terms
of the history of
music technology
were those that were released
on the Switched-on Bach album.
This was released in
1968 by Wendy Carlos
and featured this very
unhappy looking guy, well,
I guess he-- I don't know.
It's supposed to be Bach.
He's got headphones.
And he's sitting in front
of the Moog synthesizer.
This really solidifies
some of the issues
in music and technology that
we've seen again and again.
In order for new instruments
to be successful,
they often need to be tied
to historical practice.
And if you want to
legitimize an instrument,
well, play Bach on it.
And if you can play Bach on it,
then it's got to be legitimate.
Quotes of Moog and others
talk about the importance
of this album in showing people
what this thing was-- what
the synthesizer was,
that it could be used
as a musical
instrument and really,
inspired a whole generation
or generations of musicians
to become interested
in the Moog.
They say that sales
of the Moog exploded
after the release of this album,
at least for a couple of years,
even though the Moog
was so expensive.
So I had you guys
listen to two-- refresh
our memory of these.
First, "Cantata 147."
[MUSIC -- JS BACH, "CANTATA
147"]
Notice there.
This is one of my favorite
timbres in this whole album.
That's a filtered noise
sound you can hear there.
But it's got a little bit of
modulation on the frequency.
So it's kind of like there's
a little vibrato on it.
[MUSIC -- JS BACH, "CANTATA
147"]
So there's that, and then
"Well-Tempered Clavier, Book 1,
Prelude and Fugue in C Minor."
[MUSIC -- JS BACH, "THE
WELL-TEMPERED CLAVIER, BOOK 1,
PRELUDE AND FUGUE IN C MINOR"]
Nice, huh?
What do you guys think?
AUDIENCE: I said this
earlier, but that
was my favorite part
of all the listenings.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: They
were very pleasant.
PROFESSOR: They
I mean, at the time, I
imagine for some people
they were probably
pretty jarring.
Some of the timbres in that
are pretty strident timbres.
But it's still Bach.
And it relates to
organ sounds that you
might associate some
of these sounds with.
Other observations about this?
AUDIENCE: There was
some volume modulation.
Was that done independently?
PROFESSOR: In that right there?
AUDIENCE: The last one, yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you here
it as stepped dynamics.
And that's because dynamics
was a weak point of the Moog.
You had a volume control,
but the keyboards
weren't velocity sensitive.
So adjusting volume
was difficult.
So this album was recorded
through multi-track recording.
So they could do it
in the mixing process
of recording different
layers or adjusting--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it
seemed a little--
PROFESSOR: --the knobs.
It seems a little
artificial, yeah.
You hear the step
dynamics there.
AUDIENCE: So did that
[INAUDIBLE] portable
synthesizers, the red one with
the keyboard that we looked
at earlier, have touch-sensitive
keys so the performer could
actually express dynamics
without having to--
PROFESSOR: I'm not sure if
they were just on-off switches
or if they had some sort of
the more contact the louder,
or something of the sort.
That would be
something to look at.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ribbon-style controller
up and down, like they're
higher on key or lower on key.
I'd notice that.
But I don't know if
it knows how loud.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yeah.
We have many devices--
even Moog explored
in ribbons-- that would use
a lateral movement for pitch.
But I'm not sure when we got
a really flexible amplitude
control into our synths.
AUDIENCE: Was any
of that sequenced?
PROFESSOR: It wasn't sequenced.
It was all performed live.
But it's a mistake
to think of this
as just a demonstration
of the Moog synth.
This composition
was a demonstration
of the Moog synth and some very
excellent multi-track recording
and audio production.
Because this was all
composed and performed
one part at a time,
recorded to tape,
and layered one part at a time.
Remember, the Moog
synth is essentially
a monophonic instrument
at this time.
And so she had to play one
part at a time, and layer,
and re-record, and every
time, adjusting the timbre.
In many ways, this album--
I really recommend you guys
listen to the whole album,
because it's fantastic.
It's a catalog of sounds you can
make with the Moog synthesizer
and served as a catalog for
many others afterwards, going,
what was that sound?
What was that sound?
Trying to get the sounds from
that album-- really a resource
for many other
musicians, I think.
Other comments about this?
AUDIENCE: There was a
bit in the reading that
says that Carlos
commissioned Moog
to build touch-sensitive
keyboards that
had velocity control.
PROFESSOR: Oh, that's great.
Was it before or after this?
AUDIENCE: It must've been after.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: I can't
imagine why you'd
want to [INAUDIBLE]
the volume control.
PROFESSOR: That's
interesting, yeah.
She worked with
Moog quite a bit.
She worked with Moog to
create that Moog demo
LP, which I sent you
guys the link to.
She worked with Moog, I think,
to improve the sequencer
design.
And that's an interesting issue
about the touch-sensitive,
volume-sensitive keyboard.
It'd be interesting to
see when that came in
and how that was applied.
So that was a key
point in our history
of music and technology,
the legitimization
of the instrument through Bach.
Now something totally
different comes to us
from the Netherlands.
And this is a composition
by Gottfried Michael Koenig,
a German composer who had
been living and working
in the Netherlands.
And he was the artistic
director of a place called
the Institute of Sonology,
first in Utrecht and now
in the Hague, where
they had over a period
of a number of years, developed
their own modular synthesizer
from scratch.
So while Moog led to the
first commercial packaged
synthesizer, many
people were developing
custom-built synthesizers
that looked something
like this, where you have
numerous individual components
often custom designed,
scattered around the room,
and a giant patch bay to
connect them all together.
This synthesizer is
still in existence.
In fact, I took this
photo five years ago.
This isn't historical.
It looks like that still.
And it sounds fantastic.
It's an amazing-sounding
synthesizer.
His composition that we
listened to-- "Gray Function,"
is how it translates-- is part
of a series of function pieces
that explored automating
some of the parameters
of the modular synthesizer
using a single control
voltage as a pattern
that was applied
to numerous different parameters
of a synthesis system.
We can hear a little bit of
this piece to remind you.
[MUSIC -- GOTTFRIED MICHAEL
KOENIG, "GRAY FUNCTION"]
Now this piece was
composed for four channels.
And the four channels were
composed independently.
So you can hear that in
this two-channel mix.
You can hear the four
sources independently moving.
Thoughts about this piece?
Is it still going? [LAUGHS]
That was interesting. [LAUGHS]
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: I like
the Carlos better.
But it's interesting.
PROFESSOR: It's a
little more melodic.
AUDIENCE: It's
interesting in terms
of the technical aspect
of how it was created.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I think
of this piece providing
a landscape of noise
textures that we can make.
Often, we hear these
oscillators combined and used
for pitch sounds.
This composition really
gives us a sampling
of the variety of noise
timbres that could be produced.
The Institute of
Sonology synthesizer also
features a number
of modules not found
on the Moog-- for instance,
voltage-controlled envelope
generators, so where the
attack, decay, sustain,
release parameters
could be controlled
by voltages, which is
pretty interesting.
So if you think
about that, you could
set the attack and the
release of a series of sounds
to be controlled by a
low-frequency oscillator
or something else,
which allows you
to create series of
dynamic envelopes.
So moving on-- Subotnick,
"Silver Apples of the Moon."
This piece was composed
with a Buchla synthesizer.
It's not exactly clear how
much multi-track layering
was going on in the
production of this.
It's not clear if
this was one set up,
or if it was multiple
takes of layer.
That's something to look at
in the production of this.
This composition
was noted for being
one of the first recordings
made for commercial distribution
with a synthesizer.
It actually predates
Switched-on Bach by a few years
but didn't have quite
the commercial success
of Switched-on Bach.
Let's listen to a
little bit of this.
[MUSIC -- MORTON SUBOTNICK,
"SILVER APPLES OF THE MOON"]
Notice the filtered
noise timbres
coming out of the
speaker right there.
Notice, also, the--
say you had a Buchla
and you wanted to create
that flute-like sound,
how might you do that?
Any ideas?
It sounds to me like an
oscillator with a glide time,
with its pitch being controlled
by a sample and hold.
Although we're only getting
a few couple pitches,
that might be a way that
some of the frequencies
are chosen in this
composition, using a sample
and hold adjusted and shifted
to control the frequencies.
What sort of musical
roles are we hearing?
Are we hearing
musical roles or parts
that sound like
acoustic instruments,
or musical roles
or parts that sound
like something
totally different?
I think that's a
useful way for us
to approach some
of these pieces.
With the Carlos,
we hear synthesizer
being used to emulate
parts that were
done by acoustic instruments.
In the Koenig
composition, we heard
sounds that sound nothing
like acoustic instruments.
With this, we have
a nice mixture
of sounds that are
somewhat acoustic-sounding
in their roles and
somewhat electronic.
Let's listen to a little bit
and think about which is which.
[MUSIC -- MORTON SUBOTNICK,
"SILVER APPLES OF THE MOON"]
Well, that was a good
point to do that.
Because our initial
flute-like sound
transformed into a something
that a flute player
couldn't normally do.
Now in Part B of this, we
get a very surprising change.
[MUSIC -- MORTON SUBOTNICK,
"SILVER APPLES OF THE MOON"]
We get this rhythmic section
building up at the end here.
[MUSIC -- MORTON SUBOTNICK,
"SILVER APPLES OF THE MOON"]
Now Buchla's early
synthesizers were often notable
for the use of both
randomness and sequencers.
So we had various types
of random controllers
that were pretty novel.
Your book mentions
that one of them
was called a Source
of Uncertainty, which
is a very evocative name
for a random generator,
and also had
dedicated sequencers.
We're going to talk about
sequencers next time we meet.
But we hear there some
use of the sequencer
to create patterns
of voltages that
are applied to pitch or
other musical parameters.
Reflections on this piece?
Did you like it?
AUDIENCE: It is long.
PROFESSOR: It is long.
AUDIENCE: The first
part, in Part A,
the noise, I guess, sort of
sounds like the [INAUDIBLE].
I think it had like the
[INAUDIBLE] in there.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Did you hear accelerating and
de-accelerating articulations?
AUDIENCE: Sort of.
Like for real.
Just the timbre really
matched the usual [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE] start out
with that one [INAUDIBLE],
but that timbre's faster.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
that's interesting.
Although that was--
you sampled here,
these are all synthesized.
But yeah, that's
a good connection.
Anything else?
I think the depth
of this composition
is pretty remarkable.
There's just so much
going on in terms
of background and
foreground that
makes it such a
thick composition.
There had to be
multi-track layering
going on in this
composition, I think.
Either that, or they hooked up
numerous synths all together
in some massive piece.
All right.
We had the Oliveros as
well, which is probably
the one of the most novel
compositions in that it
doesn't sound at all
like Western instruments
but really takes advantage
of the synthesizer
in some unique ways.
Next time we meet, we're going
to talk about the sequencer
and continue our trajectory
up to drum machines.
I'll see you then.
See you guys.